joining me now is gary byrne a former
secret service agent gary
these guys wouldn't have been discovered
at all were it not for an arbitrary
postal service investigation of all
things tar hazarde claimed to be working
for homeland security's u.s secret
special police investigative unit the
postal inspector quickly realized that
no such agency existed how does this
happen for two years gary without these
guys being found out
well i'll tell you how it happens it
happens one of the problems with most of
the secret service employees is they're
overworked and they're exhausted and i
know it sounds bizarre that um they were
living in these departments for free and
and you're right they should have been
asking questions and their radar should
have been up
and my first question is is how
convincing were these guys if the postal
service investigator stumbled onto it in
about two minutes
how did they not and i have a lot of
questions too about it
and uh most importantly
all this information that could have
been gathered
while these people were using these
apartments like where is that
information
could this be a foreign op
how widespread do you think operations
like this are gary and how compromised
do you think our law enforcement
agencies could be
well you know based on my my uh long
experience over 29 years you know this
is this
sounds like the the honeypot scam we
were trained on back in the 80s you know
the foreign intelligence agencies using
women to
uh persuade you instead they were using
firearms free apartments
and um
you should always be on the lookout for
that and and your other guest was
correct they shouldn't be taking any
gifts with
you know they should be asking questions
and for it to go on this long and then
to be stumbled on by another agency
you know the secret service um
has got a lot of answer for the problem
is is
through the history of the secret
service they're less than honest at
times when it comes to looking at
themselves
how gullible are these people i mean the
the secret service to be taken in uh in
this way and do you think there might be
a romantic entanglement given you know
at least one of these defendants uh
history with women
well so
you know to say that they're your your
question how gullible they are you know
typically we're not typically people in
the secret service are very suspicious
these these i'm guessing these two men
were very charming they were throwing
around a lot of money and and they did
believe i guess at least a little bit
that that's who they really were i mean
they certainly they had they had the
right kind of vehicle they had they had
the right kind of
tactical equipment they had firearms um
these people bought a hook line and
sinker because they wanted to and like i
said one of the things you got to look
at is is the workload on these on these
people and how fatigued they are all the
time and exhausting
well gary i mean i appreciate that look
nobody has greater respect than we do
for our law enforcement people so many
who put their lives on the line but when
our national security apparatus is
compromised to this degree and by by two
guys who were just blundering around you
know with with fake badges and a lot of
armaments one has to worry about
what what's happening to our other
agencies and where is the cross-agency
communication gary i've got 10 seconds
give me your answer okay
so cross-agency communication is is a
fantasy
everybody talks about it they all swear
up and down i'm sure as i'm speaking
they're gonna they're gonna be repeating
it tomorrow it doesn't really happen
that much it doesn't happen that well
they're all trying to protect their own
images because they want bigger budgets
to expand their agencies that's that's
what my experience was i thank you i
thank you for the perspective and the
insight tonight hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else